k pin digitato ma no non adesso
sono stato vittima è ok per rom
io sono tutta la rosa oggi perché
fermeremo dalla nuova bbk ora più
cattiva ancora più paura sono ben otto
fa non mi seguito ancora società mi ha
mandato a seguirmi la verità orecchini
di oggi abbiamo dei lecca lecca culo
bravo la bocca
eccoci qua allora sì scritto dobbiamo
scappare prima che arrivi picchi ok
iniziamo in fundo adoro il fatto che ci
sono un sacco di cose rosa le trappole
sono rosa perché sono tema up intima e
messo degli orecchini con la fragola nel
gioco calo delle fragole
ok evitiamo quale ma a tre ecco vitale
che il primo sfracella ogni volta che
dice limitarmi di giorgio orano anche io
chi vuole contare quante volte ti sta
accellerando frase lazio ce la farà
vitale ce la farà ci si guarda sono già
più avanti di un set di pighi
inquietante che ci sono tante fette si è
iscritto spero che le altezze non ti
spaventi non ho potere alta m cosa vuol
dire tu dove sei finito sono qui devo
saltare
sì penso di sì ma ti aiuto io ti ho
visto passare a film commedia bindi giga
una big gigante con le cornee leali è un
diavoletto di vito de vue pighi
quindi questo è una nuova pdf ed ept
diavolo c'è scritto devil pighi snow cup
i primi il pd non è felice
eccola pighi diavolo è anche la giuve di
cosa è molto inquietante
no super difficile questa parte la piano
piano rincorsa
haiti ero arrivato alla fine comunque
l'ultimo pezzo non sono riuscito a
saltare non so perché la faccia di pighi
si porta sfortuna
no no devi per far sì sì allora per un
secondo
evviva diventa sempre più difficile il
corpo la cosa lì nella lava è molto
complicato sono tipo le i puzzle con il
lago facciata vitale casa dai abbiamo
scoperto capiamo fare da pd dia o dai
vitale puoi farcela puoi farcela che ho
fatto dai contiamo di
papa non l'ho visto che se avevano un
altro no tav ha fatto dai raggiunge
viper stocker e attento e molto facile
cadere d'acqua che ci sono queste altre
scale e guai se questo come l'impresa
che andremo molto spesso ce l'ha fatta
non si crede un pavimento quei buchi si
o no
lava questa e una delle scritte che ce
la posso fare
ce la posso fare questa super difficile
io quelle cipollini sono il caso abbiamo
messo in mezzo ora superare questa
partita perché qui c'è l'altra no troppo
di pizzo fosse caduto il giovane che
questo è abbastanza difficile
si dovrebbero piacere queste skyroom
siamo fase ci siamo quasi riuscito dai
che aspetto così un portale per con i
figli andiamo siamo finiti c'è scritto
qualcuno si è dimenticato di fare i
compiti
google guarda siamo in una scuola
esistono gli armadietti delle matite di
carica vitale sfracellata della colla
gigante dei pastelli a cera è
difficilissimo questa parte qui è come
se parolisi non sono riuscito ad andare
oltre e crudi tale sono inciampato su
una matita e cosa un colore pastello
nicolas che è uscita ma ma ma ma
funziona neanche questo abbiamo bloccato
forse bisogna prima questo allora
vediamo forza bisogna aprire la porta in
qualche modo parte sia una chiave
nascosta ma da qualche parte
allora c'è qualcun altro che sta
arrivando la giovedì sicuramente faranno
più bravi di piacere ecco la grande dove
prendere la chiave io comunque cerco
ancora nel frattempo adesso mi devo
farlo girare come negli armadietti di
nascondere qualcosa
vediamo cosa fa questa persona anche
loro non riescono ad entrare non sono
ragazzi siamo tipo da mezz'ora che
proviamo a capire come andare a livello
14 ma è tutto bloccato abbiamo provato a
cercare una chiave qualcosa ma non c'è
niente anche gli altri giocatori non so
che cosa bisogna fare quindi mi sa che è
vaga tra gioco va passiamo al prossimo
nuovo gioco picco che il prossimo gioco
che abbiamo deciso invece di fare un
escape room parkour abbiamo deciso di
giocare a pighi classico no in questo
pighi siamo in cielo
certo falso ping icon 100 giocatori
tra l'altro come siamo tutti uguali come
facciamo riconoscerci tutti i picchi al
momento abbiamo giocato appena diverse
c'era solo un pd e gli altri dovevano
scappare esatto perché è successo questo
rumore forse pighi deve ancora essere
assegnato dove forse ci possiamo già a
muovere visto che c'è aiuto chi va bene
neanche che cosa è successo non ho
capito
eccolo di nuovo il contrario
il suo motore è cambiata non capisco qua
sotto
dove sei non ti vedo beh è impossibile
trovarli siamo tutti uguali gli
scappiamo dobbiamo sopravvivere dice
ancora non sono riuscito a vederlo poi
c'è anche una prigione forse pdt chiude
anche in prigione e cotignolesi di a
trovarci il seme rapporto pv scappa
scappa ti sta seguendo pace roba da
mangiare che bello se posso vedere
qualcosa un po di frutta
questo codice qui sono uscita fuori
anch'io penny eccoti qua c'è qualcosa
che non va stai bene sorella maggiore
aspetta torna indietro
ma che cosa sta succedendo non mi sento
bene
no non adesso ci stiamo trasformando in
primi e cattivo cosa succede
ok ci siamo appena risvegliati ok
abbiamo selezionato questa scuola non
abbiamo capito che prima non abbiamo
perso non lo so ora siamo in picture
tubes aiuto che stava ricorrendo qui di
questo tipo bookbook due quindi il
secondo libro di pighi siamo dentro
centro commerciale abbonato
cos'era quella cosa inquietante
trovatore ho fatto un allarme abbiamo
nuovamente sbagliato quello di prima non
è abortivo forse era uno non è comunque
questo ebook chiuse anche un'offerta di
lupo e vediamo allora in questo siamo
queste sì e 6 no mi sa che non siamo
nella stessa stanza
no no vitale non è capitata la mia
stazza ma cosa devo fare devo trovare
degli oggetti questo più complicato si
parla di entrare nei nei vari negozi qui
nelle varie porte che cos'è un magazzino
ciao grande bravo a fare dovrà offrire
qualcosa mattone picchi non ci arriverà
sicuramente all'incrocio per presentarsi
qualche vuole un cazzo dici che
ricordiamo c'è una p serve qualcosa per
bollire l'acqua non riuscirà a passare
qua insomma devo trovare un sacco di
oggetti di un pò inquietante
no era un giocatore ma quello che dicono
mi scappano perché big it è trasformata
il lupo si è baciato pighi e dietro
attenzione eli eli eli scappa scappa
scritta no io si è nascosto lì perchè ho
visto una utenza che mi abbia visto
stiamo giocando a nascondino per
scappare aiuto non ha detto siamo messi
fuori
ok ha perso le mie tracce per fortuna
nasconditi in qualche negozio a questo
non si può volere entrare così lo
chiamano car ma forse perché si vuole la
chiave di quel colore
nomi di nuovo muso in che stato si è
incastrata no mi potrei mai entrato
dentro abbassati con contro chi non
negozio un po inquietante questo pd 2
prevista marcato da papa
vediamo se le spade aprire questo bene
questi erano i conti ciò che abbiamo
fatto abbiamo provato la7 un mi piace se
volete che facciamo perché granny o
baldi o nello nei non mi piace 8 e ora
vi lasciamo qualcosa per sapere se
cliccate pro dei nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
relazione